شكرا مريم مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا هذه النافذه
للتحليل العسكري نتابع فيها مجريات حرب
اسرائيل على قطاع غزه ميدانيا وبنظره
تحليليه مع المحلل العسكري اللواء فياز
الدويري مرحبا بك سيد فايز لكن دعونا
بدايه نتابع عبر الخريطه التفاعليه كيف
تجري المعارك على الارض وكيف تتوغل قوات
الاحتلال وخريطه الاشتباكات التي التي
تقوم بها المقاومه الفلسطينيه مع قوات
الاحتلال في محاور التوغل والزميل محمود
الكن محمود نعم حسن بالفعل هناك معار
معارك ضاريه في جنوب قطاع غزه تحديدا في
خان يونس لكن دعنا نحاول ان نرى هذه
الصوره بشكل اكبر من ثلاث مناطق في هذا
القطاع المنطقه الاولى التي نراها هي في
شمال غزه المنطقه الثانيه هي الوسط
والمنطقه الثالثه هي في جنوب غزه الان هذا
هذه هي المناطق التي يمكن النظر اليها
هناك هناك مجموعه من ال الالويه تقوم
بالعمل في هذه المناطق هذه المناطق هي
كالتالي هنا ثلاث الويه تعمل في شمال قطاع
غزه اضافه الى ثلاثه الويه في الوسط ويضاف
الى ذلك نحو ثمان الويه تعمل هنا في جنوب
خان يونس او في جنوب قطاع غزه في خان يونس
هذه هي مدى ضراوه هذه المعارك في خان يونس
المناورات تحدث على الشكل التالي كان هناك
قصف في المنطقه الوسطى بالقرب من شمال
القراره وفي هذه المناطق يمكن قراءتها
وسنترك ذلك بطبيعه الحال في المنطقه
الوسطى الهدف ربما في استمرار القطع ما
بين المنطقه الشماليه والوسط اضافه لمنطقه
الجنوبيه في المنطقه الجنوبيه هو كالتالي
هنا سنشاهد طبعا كان هناك قصف شمال
القراره لكن التوغل والمناورات بالاصح
المناورات الاسرائيليه تختلف تكتيكاتها
خلال الفتره الاخيره
هنا تعتمد بشكل رئيسي على الدخول من شارع
صلاح الدين الى خانيونس كنا نسمع كثير
عن الاستهدافات في محيط مستشفى ناصر
مستشفى الامل وغيرها هنا في هذه المناطق
وبالتالي محاوله من الضغط محاوله الضغط من
الشمال ايضا من الشمال الغربي باتجاه
مدينه خان يونس وايضا من الجنوب الشرقي
كما شاهدنا من شارع صلاح الدين كيف تعمل
هذه الالويه هنا سنشاهد هذه
الصوره
هذه الصوره هي لعدد الالويه التي وانواع
الالويه التي تعمل في منطقه خان
يونس التوزع هو كالتالي التوزع هنا هناك
لواء للمظليين
لواء للمشاه ثلاثه الويه مدرعه ولواء
كوماندو او لواء قوات خاصه هذا هو الثقل
الذي ياتي على خان يونس في حين هناك ثلاثه
الويه في الوسط اضافه الى ثلاثه الويه
وكتيبه في الشمال هناك المزيد من التحليل
العسكري بسبب هذا الوضع معكما حسن واللواء
فايز وكيف يمكن قراءه هذا الثقل العسكري
في شكرا لك محمود فعلا السؤال موجه ل فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري كيف يمكن قراءه
هذا الثقل العسكري في خانيونس وعمليا ما
هو الهدف الاسرائيلي من خان يونس وهل هو
سيناريو مكرر لما حصل في الشمال وحصل في
الوسط هو بعد انتهاء المرحله الاولى وبدات
المرحله الثانيه كان القرار سواء على
مستوى القياده
السياسيه او القياده العسكريه وجميعهم
تحدث بنفس الاتجاه بان المعركه ستكون اوسع
نطاقا اكثف
وسيتم العمل
بالتزامن ماذا يعني
بالتزامن التزامن كان في المنطقه
الشماليه والكل يذكر ماذا جرى بعد الهدنه
دخول اخر ولكن القتال
انتقل
مراكز المواقف الساخنه والاشتباكات
العميقه في المرحله الاولى كانت في
المنطقه الغربيه والشماليه في المرحله
الثانيه ت كان هناك قتال لكن تركز في
المنطقه الشرقيه بدا بالشجاع وانتقل الى
تفاح وجباليا ومن ثم قيل حسب ما يتحدث
وزير ال الدفاع جالانت بانه دانت السيطره
تم تفكيك حماس والان ندخل بالمرحله
الثالثه الان قبل الدخول بالمرحله الثالثه
كانت هناك تزامن ما بين المنطقه الشماليه
والمنطقه الجنوبيه في البدايه ومن ثم دخلت
المنطقه الوسطى على الخط لاحقا لاحظ كانت
المعارك في الشمال والمعارك في الجنوب
بينما الوسط كان لا يزال خارج اطار
المعركه عندما تم سحب الفرق الثلاث نعم تم
ارسال الفرقه 36 المدرعه الى المنطقه
الوسطى وفشلت في اداء مهمتها وتم
استبدالها بالفرقه 99 واللي هي الان يوجد
فيها محمود اشار الى ثلاثه الويه كان فيها
اربعه الويه لانه كان لواء من الفرقه 36
ملحق وكان هناك لواء احتياط موجودات في
منطقه وادي غزه تم سحبهم الى منطقه السياج
نعم الان المنطقه الوسطى القتال فيها كان
اي في بدايته محاوله الت انا اتحدث هنا عن
منطقه البريج سيارات الزوايده المغازي لما
بدا القتال باشراف الفرقه
99 الان تم اعاده صياغه المقاربه العسكريه
و اعتمد مبدا تجزئه المجزا طيب الان تم
الفصل ما بين هذه المخيمات الاربعه ولكن
القتال لم يحقق ايه انجازات يعتد بها
باستثناء اجزاء من المغازي واجزاء من
الزوايده واجزاء الجنوبيه من البريج الان
نذهب الى منطقه الثقل الرئيسي في القتال
وهي المنطقه الجنوبيه وهذا ما اود ان اصل
اليه معك خانيونس منطقه خانيونس بدا
القتال تقريبا له اكثر من من شهرين وبدا
القتال بكثافه كبيره جدا بدا بخمسه الويه
زيدت الى سته الويه زيدت الى سبعه الويه
زيدت الى ثمانيه الويه جميعها تحم تعمل
تحت مظله او وتحت الاداره العملياتي
للفرقه
98 عندما بدا الهجوم بدا الهجوم من كسوفين
باتجاه القراره كان كان التخطيط ان
العمليه العسكريه ستكون مختلفه اي في
جوهرها وان تشابهت في اطارها الخارجي نعم
كان العمل كما نذكر المعركه في الشمال
بدات بهجوم من من وادي غزه وانعطف شمالا
وبدات من الشمال
من اقصى نقطه مع ال شارع الرشيد والتقوا
ودخلوا من التوام ومن منطقه مجمع الشفاء
الى شارع النصر وجرى ما جرى هنا حاولوا
تطبيق نفس المقاربه فانطلقوا من الشمال من
كوس فيم الى القراره الى شارع صلاح الدين
الى منطقه المطاحن الى مدينه الحمد وثم
انعطف باتجاه ما يطلق عليها منطقه المواسي
وجوش قطيف وتوقفت القوات في تلك المنطقه
لجمله اسباب ه هذا الهجوم كان هو المرحله
الاولى الفرعيه من المرحله الرئيسيه
الثانيه المرحله الثانيه من هذا الهجوم
وكانت متداخله في الزمان كانت متداخله لا
اقول متوازيه بالمطلق بدا الهجوم من منطقه
الزنه ومن شمال عبسان الجديده وصولا الى
شارع صلاح الدين ومن جنوب عبسان الكبيره
بنفس الاتجاه باي باي هدف يعني انت تتحدث
من القراره نزولا ومن عبسان
العمل العمليه الاحاطه كانت تهدف الى
الوصول الى مدينه خان يونس نعم فيما
المنطقه التي تقع شرق شارع صلاح الدين هي
اوسع واصعب وبالتالي متوقع ان تكون هي
الموقعه الحاسمه فحاولوا ان يتخطوها من
خلال هجمات من الجوانب من شمال عبسان ومن
جنوب عبسان ولكن بالتالي ماذا حصل عمليه
الاحاطه لم تؤتي
نتائج لم تقدم نتائج حاسمه ما ظهر ظهر هنا
نقطتين كانت مؤلما بالنسبه لجيش الاحتلال
خزاعه اذا نلاحظ في اسفل الخارطه والقرار
في اعلى الخارطه اصبحت هذه كانها الصنو
لجحر الديك وبالتالي الكل يعرف جحر الديك
والعمليات الت نفذت في جحر الديك وبدات
العمليات انطلق من خزاعه وال قراره هذا
اعاد هيكله العمليه العسكريه تم دفع اعاده
لوائين تخصيصه الى منطقه الزنيه والقاره
وتم اعاده لواء تخصيصه الى خزاعه طيب ابدا
بعجاله خزاعه ماذا جرى فيها استمر القتال
لاكثر من اسبوع عشره ايام لم تستطع دخولها
فانكا اللواء الى منطقه السياج في القراره
وزنه لم تستطع ان تحقق نتائج دمرت كل شيء
معظم الاشياء ومن ثم انسحبت باتجاه كوسي
فيم لاعاده التاهيل فكانت المناوره
الاخيره من جنوب خزاعه من منطقه الفخاري
وصولا الى خال يونس الى منطقه قيزان
النجار عمليا عمليا هناك قوات احتلال
توغلت الى خانيونس نعم وهناك اشتباكات
تجري في خانيونس داخل خانيونس لكن الان
بحسب ما تتوقع او بحسب رؤيتك للمجريات
العسكريه ما الهدف داخل خان يونس وما هي
المناطق الاكثر استهدافا بالنسبه لجيش
الاحتلال في هذه المن اولا هناك خلافات
واضحه جدا بين القراءه السياسيه والقراءه
العسكريه وهناك حتى خلافات داخل القياده
السياسيه اذا اعتبرنا مجلس الحرب يمثل
الواجهه السياسيه هناك خلافات بين ايزنكوت
وغيره مع وزير الدفاع ومع نتنياهو وهناك
خلافات اقل فجوه ما بين جلنت ونتنياهو
وهناك خلافات ما بين الكل نصف المجلس
الحرب مع مع هاليفي رئيس الاركان وتالي
على خلافات حول حول ماذا يعني كقائد عسكري
ميدانيا انا اتحدث بالجانب العسكري نحث
اتحدث ميدانيا الان قائد القائد العسكري
للعمليه يجب ان تكون الاوضا الاهداف واضحه
الان ما هي
الاهداف القضاء على حماس واستعاده الاشراء
هل هذه هل هذه الاهداف يمكن ترجمتها
بعمليه عسكريه صعب جدا لماذا لانه انت
تتعامل مع مجهول اين قاده حماس هلهم في
الزنه هلهم في بن سي هلهم في القراره هل
هم في داخل خان يونس هناك فشل استخباري
متجذر من قبل سبعه من قبل طوفان الاقصى 7
اكتوبر الى اللحظه اللي اتحدث فيها
وبالتالي لا يوجد فكره ولا توجد ولا يوجد
بنك معلومات يفضي الامر الاخر ما هو الهدف
الاخر استعاده الاشرا اين هم فيما يتعلق
بقاده حماس وجدوا
صوره ل بطاقته والسنوار كما قالها احمد
الطيب وجدوا فرده حذاء للسنوار
وبالتالي عن عن الرهائن ماذا وجدوا بالامس
تحدثوا انه تم اكتشاف احد الانفاق وفيه
اثار تدل على انه كان هنا نعم اذا اذا
الاهداف الاهداف من الصعب تحديدها
واسقاطها على موقع معين لهذا السبب هناك
ضبابيه وهذا ما تحدث عنه هليفي بصراحه قال
عدم وضوح الرؤيه تؤدي الى تاكل الانجازات
عمليا هذا يفترض اعاده النظر بكل الع
العمليه العسكريه يعني اذا كانت الاهداف
غير واضحه لكن ما يحصل عمليا انه عمليات
التوغل مستمره المعارك مستمره والخطه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه مستمره حتى حتى بدون
اهداف كما تقول الان
حقيقه هل الرهائن هم الهدف هذا سؤال لا
لسبب تم انقاذ 110 خلال سبع ايام في
الهدنه ولم يتم انقاذ ولا رهينه خلال 110
ايام مش هذا ما جرى على الارض طيب
اثنين القضاء على حماس هدف لا اكمل في
الجزئيه الاولى قانون هاني باعل
ارس نشرت هذا اليوم عن مقتل ثلاثه في
الانفاق باستخدام
الغازات في هذا اليوم نعم اذا لاحظ لم تعد
الرهائن وهذا ما يتحدث به الشرع الاسرا
اولويه لم يع اولويه على اجنده نتنياهو
على الاقل وقلن قاده حماس كيف سيعثر عليه
كان اخ اخر اخر معلومه استخباريه يوجد في
اخفظ نقطه في انفاق حماس في مكان ما في
خان يونس يعني تبحث عن ابره في كومه قش
اذا دعني اقول اذا هذا يعيدني ما هو الهدف
الحقيقي والجوهري غير المعلن هنا مربط
الفرس طب هناك من يقول بان
الهدف ما ق في البدايه ومازال حتى الان
يتحدث به المسؤولون الاسرائيليون تجير انا
ساقول اعتقد ساقول ما تتحدث به وستحدث به
نيابه عنك وان وان لم اصب قلب الحقي قبد
الحقيقه تطرح في رايك انا اقول الهدف
الاساسي هو
التهجير تهجير اهل غزه بالحديث عن التهجير
الطوعي التهجير الالزامي كل ما دون ذلك هي
عباره عن رتوش فقط لا غير وللاسف هناك
مفارقه عجيبه الامريكيين يختلفوا مع
نتنياهو لكن هل تتم استخدام الادوات
الفاعله المؤثره على نتنياهو ما هي
الادوات الفاعله والمؤثره هل هناك وقف لل
الشنت العسكريه هل هناك تلويح
ب بما يتعلق بالمساعده الاقتصاديه هل هناك
تلويح باستخدام النفوذ السياسي في مجلس
الامن اذا لا يوجد ضغط حقيقي على نتنياهو
من قبل بايدن وبالتالي يبدو للاخرين ان
نتنياهو يتمرد على امريكا وهو في في
الحقيقه بممارساته يتمرد ط هل هل هذا ما
ما يفسر وهذا باختصار اود اجابه عنه هل
هذا ما يفسر عمليه القصف التي حصلت اليوم
ل مراكز ايواء سبق ان قالت قوات الاحتلال
للناس ان اذهبوا اليها هذه مناطق امنه ثم
استهدفوا
في هذه المناطق دعني اربط هذا الحدث بحدث
حدث يوم امس بالامس في شمال غزه تم
استهداف ثلاثه مدارس تابعه ل الانور وتم
اجلاء قاطنيها وهم نازحين وتم تهجيرهم عبر
البحر الى الجنوب اذا عمليه التهجير سواء
طوعي او قسري هي تجري على قدم الوساق
وعندما اقول تهجير طوعي هو في جوهره ليس
طبيعيا انت ما انت عندما تمنع كل سبل
الحياه انت في في الاخير يعتبر قسري لكن
هو بظاهره انه انا لم اجدج لم اعد اجد
شربه الماء فعلي ان اخرج فبالتالي يقال
بانه طوعي علما جميعه قسري ولكن ستبقى
العلامه الفارقه نعم ما سيجري على حدود
جمهوريه مصر العربيه فردل شكرا شكرا جزيلا
لك اللواء فيز دويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي